Ah ah ah che cos'era bello battute non
inibire Eh aspetta aspetta
un cattivo riusciva a prenderci oppure
non ci riuscirà la scopriremo questa
nuovissima Escape Room in cui dobbiamo
scappare da Jerry Cioè dobbiamo scappare
dal cinema di Jerry Jerry è quello lì
che vedete che Lo spaventapasseri
cattivo horror pauroso ma noi dovremmo
scappare dal suo cinema Infatti non ho
capito
ah ah forse sarà un film pauroso Cioè
lui è dentro alla fine no no no Non
scopriremo se vi Mettetevi comodi Prendi
i Popcorn lasciate un bel mi piace qua
sotto iniziamo subito con questa Escape
Room andiamo andiamo quindi abbiamo
Allora modalità facile o difficile
ovviamente facile perché contiamo
chiappe
Oddio Ah siamo nel cinema Beh c'è c'è il
laser in questo cinema eh Più che altro
ci sono gli zombie Cioè è stato invaso
dagli Zombie questo cinema Allora
vediamo che dice questo ragazzo il
cinema ha preso vita e si sta impostando
del palazzo come fa il cinema a prendere
vita oh Guarda che figo c'è la sala
giochi qui
ma avete visto il mio outfit di oggi vi
piace tutto rosso come me oggi invece
Vitale è sempre vestito uguale
tempo per cambiare i vestiti sempre
vestiti zozzi
Ehi Come osi superarmi sono riuscito a
passare guarda ma non capisco perché mi
sto sfracellando non ho fatto niente di
male tu devi evitare quei blocchi lì e
poi devi evitare anche quei pac-man che
che saltano da una parte all'altra da un
videogioco all'altro
è tipo una sfera di fuoco dai Hahaha
mi hai fatto sfracellare
Ora sono io avanti Qua ci sono dei degli
zombie che vomitano
di evitare il loro gobito
però Adoro questo ambientazione perché
adoro il cinema
aspettami dove sono i Popcorn dove anche
fame fame fame Eccoli qua li ho trovati
Li ho trovati prima di te guarda
Purtroppo però là dietro c'è qualcuno
che eh è morto No è morto proprio guarda
devo vedere aspetta mi sono rimaste
indietro qua con gli zombie che sputano
i laser Verdi
Uh sono riuscita a passare qua ora gli
ruba i Popcorn Aspettami Dammi da
mangiare dammi da mangiare che questi
popcorn sembrano ma sono tipo sciolti
Mmm Cacca di uccello mmm
andiamo Uh Aspettami non si va andiamo
Non sono popcorn Quindi niente Io
intanto vado avanti intanto
gioia Ma cosa c'entrerà Jerry Forse alla
fine dovremmo affrontare Jerry Lo
spaventapasseri bravo
Qual è l'ultimo film che avete visto al
cinema Scrivetemi nei commenti ed era un
bel film secondo voi vi è piaciuto
allora l'ultimo film che noi abbiamo
visto al cinema e
non me lo ricordo io me lo ricordo La
città incantata che è uno dei miei film
preferiti in assoluto solo che vi
servono non ha visto Cioè In realtà
avevo iniziato a farglielo vedere ma si
era addormentato Allora gli ho detto Ehi
ha detto che oggi ma non ti puoi
addormentare al cinema quindi andiamo a
vedere un attimo vedete bellissimo vi
consiglio di andarlo a vedere benissimo
se non l'avete visto ancora vedetelo La
città incantata di ayaz Miyazaki è
bellissimo ma ora aspettiamo Vitale
perché qua c'è tutto questo c'è una
sorpresa dietro a questa porta Quindi
vorrei che prima vedesse Vitale Qual è
la sorpresa Aspetta Allora io sono qui
che sto per arrivare ma mi sto facendo
sempre bellissimo
sbriciolato un paio di volte guardate i
Popcorn No mi sono proprio sfracellato
dai vai lì c'è una sorpresa per te
Vediamo cosa accade ah ah ah
No no del pagliaccio mi hai preso pure a
te ah ah ecco come sempre che la mia
testa pelata volando Ma che cosa è
successo
[Musica]
no Aiuto Sono finita in un loop
è buggato Ah ecco sono originali a
liberarmi Dai non andare in quella porta
No no io vado nel pc e c'era il PC
dobbiamo per maschi dice Attenzione Apri
quella porta e c'è un tunnel per
attivare lo switch che apre non so che
cosa Eh apre la porta del Aspetta ma se
io apro l'altra porta non si apre Ok ok
Sei già buttato esploriamo qua un
momento hai ragione ma che schifo
Qualcuno ha fatto la pipì verde che
invece
[Musica]
qualora voi che la faccia avevo pensato
Eh in effetti questo è il bagno degli
zombie perché è stata sorpresa dagli
Zombie questo cinema che c'è un altro
Zombie anche questo è morto questo
Zombie si è sentito male dopo aver visto
il conto non mi sorprende
vediamo quindi guarda guarda Apri leva
tiro leva Apri caffè
Guarda se sali qua sopra riesci a vedere
le Escape Room da fuori
non c'è niente qui è tutto Marrone
Dai apri la porta Sbrigatevi ad aprire
una porta ma non so dov'è tu l'hai vista
sì Ha aperto il vento c'è la finestra
come si chiama in italiano Non mi
ricordo Comunque bisogna tornare
indietro veramente sì perché mi ricordo
che l'ho vista bagno ecco son trovata Ok
sbrigarti perché una volta che entrerò
in questo labirinto tutti perderà
andiamo quindi andiamo Ehm
tutto tutto sta tornando
Ho trovato la mia uscita No io non
riesco a passare
Non ci posso credere devo tornare
indietro allora allora
te lo dico Hahaha
Pensavo fossi tu quello lì si stracciato
Vediamo se Vitale ce la faccio
ogni volta che pure tu fratello ce l'ha
data comunque
c'è mancato poco no è sempre più
difficile però l'ultima
Non ci posso credere Guarda facciamo
tipo
scappiamo anche da questa vento ma hai
notato che in queste Escape Room siamo
più piccoli
bambini tipo Ah qua bisogna buttare giù
questa Apriti Wow ho gli occhiali 3D
gigante
gli occhiali 3D giganti che cosa vedremo
uh uh perché dobbiamo saltare sopra di
questo non è neanche uno zombie
Eh sì ne dubito ma vabbè
Ma quando arriviamo al cinema Ecco gli
altri Zombie Meno male c'è questa grata
così non si prendono
ma sono scomparsi Vabbè non pensavo di
riuscire a saltare dall'altra parte Cioè
questo vuol dire che io sono in
vantaggio Ciao Anita Ciao Anita sono qua
Ciao ciao Via via via Aspetta aspetta
devo dirti una cosa Non ho capito se tu
salti dall'altra parte della grata
troverai un sacco di popcorn
complice destra ti stanno aspettando il
giro largo Ciao
Io adesso andrò a prendere il badge e tu
rimarrai indietro incastrato quindi
incartare il peggio perché appena
iniziata l'escape Room però ho già
scoperto un sacco di trucchetti di
queste Escape Room Che trucchetti eh
mica te lo dico uno zombie anche questo
è iniziato adesso Io ho quasi finito
questo stage qui hai già superato il
vomito di zombie Ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao ciao aspetta Adesso mi vedi Ciao
ciao ciao oh oh oh
oh Ma perché ogni volta che mi sfracello
mi cade la testa i capelli
no
Ma non sei brava quanto me per favore
Sono diventato Super Bravo Roblox
sono finita tipo in un universo
parallelo mi ha fatto sopra c'è scritto
Vai via vattene Ehi scappa
e sono morta di nuovo cosa succede C'è
qualcosa di strano ma si è rotta
l'escape Room Ecco qui per fortuna sono
tornata qua
[Musica]
perché sei tornato indietro perché ti
sto aspettando Ti avevo sei tornato
troppo indietro io sono quassù ma
veramente importante ti volevo far
cadere su quella grata lì arrugginito
Ehi mi dispiace ma io devo andare a
salvare perché se muoio di nuovo io ero
avanti Sono sono voluto andare indietro
per farti sfociare adesso proprio dietro
di te Dormi di nuovo devo salvare dove
il pulsante per salvare Mamma mia aiuto
Dove abita Okay dobbiamo andare andiamo
subito Ehi
e Devo avvisarti di non provare a
mangiare questi popcorn Io sinceramente
lassativo
Anita non ti sfracellare su queste cose
Verdi Eh che tu di solito non prendi mai
bene le misure qui Ah ah ah ah era uno
zombie hai visto sì
No non l'avevo capito ma pensavo che era
lui che si stesse sciogliendo No vedi
che esce tutto dalla bocca
hahaha Dai aspettiamo Vitale Anzi
lasciate un mi piace per portare gli
sfortuna ok Sono passato questo mostro
zombie che Stavo vomitando di tutto
vediamo avete portato
Fortunatamente
il cinema Ci ha mangiato No vabbè Sta
andando tutto a fuoco
sì
vai via dalla mia fattoria Oh no credo
che sia Jerry questo l'ho
spaventapasseri aiuto perché lui vive
nella fattoria perché deve fare lo
spaventapasse giustamente no Quindi
prima o poi lo incontreremo lo dovremo
affrontare forse aiuto vediamo qui a
Salva subito dobbiamo uscire presto di
questo mondo
Vedi stanno sgocciolando tutte vi
raccontiamo una cosa divertente allora
noi adoriamo le zucche e il papà di
Vitale lei coltiva Quindi ogni anno
abbiamo tantissime zucche bellissime Tra
l'altro gigantesco bellissimo e un anno
l'anno scorso quando l'anno scorso
abbiamo preso un po' di zucca e tre
zucche gigantesche bellissime e duravano
tantissimo Quindi li abbiamo lasciati in
camera anche fin dopo Halloween per
decorare la camera Il problema è che un
giorno c'era quasi dimenticato siamo
andati in vacanza non mi ricordo dove
siamo andati siamo tornate una zucca
rossa
Sì sarà tutto il liquido per terra una
puzza di zucca marcia per una settimana
anche se abbiamo pulito ogni giorno che
ho la puzza di zucca marcia e quindi
questa è la lezione di oggi non lasciate
le zucche in custodite in casa per
troppo tempo prendono vita e fanno come
quelle zucche lì
ci sarà bellissima quella zucca Allora
c'è scritto non troverai mai la via
d'uscita Hai visto che prima c'era il
palloncino rosso che stavamo seguendo
e credo che voglia dire qualcosa sapete
cosa vuol dire un palloncino rosso
ho paura qua Hai trovato la via d'uscita
no c'è un labirinto Ma è tipo è fatto
con con come si chiamano le pannocchie
sì e quindi questo qua Cioè qua potrebbe
esserci Jerry perché Lo spaventapasseri
sta qua secondo me lui ha deciso di
piantare il mais sai Per quale motivo
perché ho detto voi la via d'uscita non
la troverete mais
Guarda che c'è ancora troppo caldo qua
ti vedo ha piantato il mais per fare il
pop corn per il cinema No è intelligente
questo Jerry
Allora scappiamo da Jerry dove si
nasconde compare all'improvviso
no
scappare Credo di sì aspetta è troppo
veloce non saltare ho imparato da te che
non bisogna saltare perché sennò ti
rallenta
Prova ad andare poco poco a destra e poi
scappare sempre dritto Dritto dritto
Dritto dritto Dritto tieni tieni tieni
tieni tieni tieni tieni tieni
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto vai vai vai vai
vai corri corri corri corri corri passo
il pulsantone verde son spruzzatore
verde uh uh è scomparso
Evviva ah ah ciao ciao ciao Jerry non mi
prenderei
è scomparso non c'è più Ora posso
camminare tranquillamente
ci vorrà fare a pezzi a fette Non lo so
Ci volete trasformare in popcorn anche a
noi qua ho messo una ragnatela per
bloccare il passaggio Cioè non possiamo
più tornare indietro possiamo solo
andare avanti
Io sto continuando a sfracellarmi su
quella ragnatela Ah questa ragnatela Eh
sì quella ragnatela Non mi sembra così
Anita Ho paura che Jerry sia ritornato
qui ma di Già Uffa Non lo so un qualcosa
che sembra tipo il cimitero Il cimitero
di Cimitero dei Forconi Non lo so c'è
qualcosa che Eh ok mi sono i forconi e
lui che sta guardando dall'alto verso il
basso Aspetta sto arrivando lo vedi Te
l'ho detto no forse non è sì è Jerry
Ecco perché non si muove
come ho fatto a spregermi così dovevi
avvicinarti così tanto tempo aspetta un
attimino ma non dobbiamo saltare su
quelle cose Ah non bisogna saltare sui
forconi appuntiti non avevo capito che
Eccoci arrivati non si muove però non ci
ha visto Meno male e perché era uno
spaventapasseri magari sta dormendo
perché spaventapasseri dormono e poi
basta Dimmi che ci sono di notte Eh ogni
giorno di notte dorme Okay
Allora secondo me non dovremmo entrare
in questa casa stregata perché si vede
subito che una casa infestata Cioè
guarda e non dovrebbe entrare io faccio
un giro di qua vediamo se trovo un'altra
strada dice che dobbiamo trovare una
chiave
Ovviamente la chiave sarà per forza
dentro la casa stregata Sì penso proprio
di sì Aspetta Prova a cercare qua
vediamo magari è fuori infatti
vediamo per ora sono curiosa di vedere
cosa c'è qua dentro ah ah
forse bisogna trarre di lato Ah non si
può entrare dalla porta principale
dato che non ci sia Jerry ho una zucca
marcia
così possiamo tirarla in testa a girare
in realtà perché Cosa vediamo come arma
Allora vediamo Siamo giù nella cantina
bisogna attivare questa cosa qui forse
Ok proviamo Ok non è successo niente
ho ripremuto il pulsante per far cadere
Vitale ma non ha funzionato
OK riproviamo il pavimento e lavabo
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
giusto
sì Vediamo cosa dice qua il ragazzo cosa
dice sei riuscito a uscire dal cinema
ehm ti sei salvato ora prova ad evitare
le luci laser ok
ci sta sorvegliando da qualche parte
Jerry Guarda
mi ha preso riproviamo
poco aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
questa luce
Ehi finora non ci devo fare sellati
incredibile C'è qualcuno qua che sta
volando o no i Preferiti di Anita i
laser no vai a mio fratello sempre Milan
- Lazio bisogna saltare almeno
L'importante è che non si muovono ma
sono super altro da che parte dobbiamo
andare
volevo dire che stiamo tornando indietro
abbiamo aperto una porta Ok dobbiamo
tornare indietro forse da quell'altro
corridoio qui Proviamo speriamo che sia
una scorciatoia Non saprei Sì sì sì
almeno non dobbiamo ripassare in quel
momento
non sei Esatto
[Musica]
Aspetta aspetta che succede Ah ti senti
dentro
il vento il vento ti porta attenta
Ma cosa c'entrano in cucina
in arrivo
che Che cosa sono devono rompere le
scatole
Ok sono riuscito
[Risate]
Wow e poi si entra di nuovo di qua ok
giusto in tempo
ci sta provando dove dobbiamo andare poi
là dentro ok guarda
arrivo dopo questa scatola
[Musica]
sarà Jerry Uh corri corri corri corri no
che è successo ci ha preso qualcuno
Ah ah ah ah dovevi aspetta aspetta
aspetta
no vado Devo vincere Chi arriva prima
Ecco Perfetto
mi vedi Ok allora facciamo una gara
assieme Aspetta aspetta
partiamo pronti 3 2 1 via
[Musica]
ci sono riuscita Sono spregiudicato
invece arriverò prima
Oh No sono di nuovo finita in questo
posto inquietante Mamma mia super paura
quello Dai mettiamo il casco e andiamo
pronti 3 2 1
via sono ancora viva Non ci credo non
capisco perché mi spiace ma pure tutti
sopracciglia allora ho capito invece di
fare la gara dobbiamo andare piano piano
non credo che sia una buona tecnica
Vabbè allora io vado ciao
uh uh uh ah ah ah ah
che
schiaffeo okay riproviamo questa volta
ci riuscirò Ah Ah è vero che ci riuscirò
questa volta guarda e ti faccio vedere
come ci riesco no no
pronti
Ok il primo ostacolo superato secondo
secondo
Anita si è sfracellata io vado avanti
Ciao Sei riuscita a superare tutto come
si fa a saltare la seconda parte devi
prendere un po' di velocità e premere il
momento giusto wow wow wow non ci credo
Rida cioè quasi fatta sono quasi fatta
ci sono anch'io Windows wireless
perché sto correndo nella macchina che
succede
vado nella macchina dei Flintstones
stavo correndo con i piedi sono riuscito
ad arrivare alla fine però mi hanno
tolto la macchina ma sono rimasto seduto
come se stessi Equitalia
Ora ti raggiungo subito subito Quindi
hai già preso il badge No ancora no Ti
sto aspettando Vai vai
attenta Attenta ok adesso su quelle
barre rosse non devi saltare Vai vai
dritta così brava vai evita Uh uh uh uh
e ora l'ultima parte Brollo
Guarda guarda sono rimasto seduto io
perché Hahaha
c'ha la macchina invisibile
Complimenti Sei riuscito a scappare dal
teatro però ha vinto Vitale ha vinto
Vitale è stata troppo divertente questa
Skin strumenti da un nove e mezzo Tu
neanche io neanche io occhio Dai che
voto ha girato e scrivetelo nei commenti
e ovviamente lasciate un bel mi piace
Ora vi lasciamo
utilizzare per i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao